Speaker 1: Let's keep talking to people because
there are so many.
Let's go next to J.T. from Tallahassee.
Speaker 2: That's not Jake,
Speaker 1: but J.T. with a T. That's that's
interesting.
Speaker 4: Yes, or kind of like.
Nate, but with AJ, there's another way.
Speaker 1: That's actually much more clear,
I think that that's it.
I will say it that way for now.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: I wanted to ask you about.
The.
In Florida, I'm seeing reports that there's
Spanish language, right wing talk radio in
South Florida and it's having a it's having
a political effect.
I know there are a lot of exiled Cubans who
seem to go pretty right wing in reaction to
Cuba.
Yes, Cuba, as well as Venezuela.
It sounds like there are.
There's lots of Venezuelans who think the
same way as any speaker.
Do you have any insights onto this phenomenon?
Speaker 1: So there's a few different things.
This is a really good, important and complex
issue.
Speaker 2: And you know, the
Speaker 1: Latino electorate in American elections
is increasingly important, and we've got to
figure this out because otherwise it's not
good for the left.
So generally speaking,
Speaker 2: immigrants to
Speaker 1: the United States from Latin America
Speaker 2: tend to vote for Democrats, except
Speaker 1: the ones that don't.
Cubans do not tend to vote for Democrats.
Speaker 2: Cubans are very Republican,
Speaker 1: and they are Republican, mostly
as a reaction to they
Speaker 2: say, Well, Castro
Speaker 1: was bad and the opposite of Castro
is Republican.
Speaker 2: So that's basically that that that's
boiling it down to why that is.
Speaker 1: Very similar thing with Venezuela.
Speaker 2: Now I as a leftist who is not a
communist and who does not
Speaker 1: like authoritarian strongman
Speaker 2: regimes.
Speaker 1: My view is different.
My view is, well, good.
OK, you didn't like the regime in Cuba.
You left, you didn't like the regime in Venezuela.
You left.
Now you're in the U.S. Don't go for right
wing authoritarians.
That's not the solution.
The solution is social democracy, which is
my view.
But to get to your point, when I did my Spanish
language show around the 2020 election on
the yesterday on network, the amount of conspiratorial
Speaker 2: thinking, all of the
Speaker 1: same conspiracies that we see on
Facebook in English, they were spreading like
wildfire within Spanish language groups.
In comments in response to the clips, I was
doing, the emails, et cetera.
So the best advice for the left would be you
need to
Speaker 2: understand that this is an electorate
that you need
Speaker 1: that we need and you need to weigh
more proactively, be going out there and preventing
folks
Speaker 2: who come to the U.S. and just getting
Speaker 1: these
Speaker 2: right wing Latino echo
Speaker 1: chambers.
Because even if most of the
Speaker 2: voters tend to go
Speaker 1: to the left radio, right wing radio
Speaker 2: right wing Spanish
Speaker 1: language radio in Florida is influencing
a lot of these folks who are like, Well, it's
the one thing in Spanish, so I'm going to
listen to it and it's wacky, far right stuff,
and the left has to figure out a strategy
on it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's good.
I didn't realize that you had a Spanish-Language
show in 2020.
Yeah, we
Speaker 1: did like 13 weeks basically like
leading up to the election and through the
inauguration.
Speaker 4: Very interesting.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: You can even check out my Spanish
language interview with L.A. Mayor Eric Garcetti
on my YouTube channel.
Speaker 4: Oh, unfortunately, I would not
be able to understand it.
Speaker 1: Well, it's subtitled Don't worry.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, as a as a final thing, I think I remember
you talking about the election fraud that
occurred.
Now this is actually real election fraud here
in Florida.
And that was when some fake candidates were
were put up in the state legislature.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And the right term, I mean, calling them fake
is funny, but it's there.
So they would be like straw candidates.
Their candidates made to take away votes from
your
Speaker 2: opponent and organized
Speaker 1: by a different
Speaker 2: candidate.
Yeah, and that's
Speaker 1: against the law to do.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Like, I think you talked about it before,
you weren't sure what exactly it happened
in terms of prosecution, but it looks like
in one of the races the they actually prosecuted
him for four, I think some kind of campaign
finance violation and there was a former state
legislature legislator as well.
Yeah.
And he pled guilty in the race that the Republican
won by thirty
Speaker 2: two points, not thirty
Speaker 4: two point thirty two
Speaker 2: votes.
Thirty votes.
Okay.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
So he actually pled guilty.
And then the article I just read said he was
all apologetic and stuff like that.
Speaker 1: Oh, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Well, yeah, I know.
And the straw candidate thing, we're going
to be watching it very closely in 2022.
All right, my friend.
Appreciate the call.
Very much.
Speaker 4: All right.
Sure.
All right.
There we go.